-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game
called "What's Behind Me?"
My partner tonight
is an incredible actress.
Her new movie, "Eileen,"
is in theaters everywhere today.
Please give it up for the one
and only Anne Hathaway!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Hello!
-I love you! Hey!
-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-Alright,
here's how the game works.
Okay, Anne and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain
will be something
neither of us has seen before.
Could be people, could be
objects, could be anything.
Once the curtain opens
and you pick up your card,
you have 45 seconds
to try to get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want.
You can use gestures.
You just can't say
any of the words
on your card.
Anne, you'll be guessing first.
-Oh.
-Let's get into position.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Hey! [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Okay, here we go. Okay.
-Okay.
-Anne, let's open the curtain
and see what's behind you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Okay.
-It is, uh, it is
five of these characters.
It's a Timothee Chalamet movie
out soon.
-Oompa-Loompas.
-Yeah, but the name
of the movie. Yes.
-Oh, Wonkas.
-Yes.
-Willy Wonka.
-Yes. Okay.
Yeah. That's good.
-Okay.
-They are in an underground --
-Five Wonkas?
-Yes, five Wonkas.
-Okay. It just landed.
-Five Wonkas. They're doing --
They're in an underground --
-Tunnel?
-Kind of.
But it's a rock formation.
-Rock? Cave.
-Yes.
-And they're like --
[ Imitating drums ]
-And they're playing the drums.
They're at a rave.
-Yes, that's it!
That's correct!
[ Dinging ]
Five Wonkas having a rave
in a cave.
That's exactly right.
-That's exactly what's
happening.
-Five Wonkas having a rave
in a cave.
There you go. I love it.
Fantastic.
-Literal.
-Very nice. Thank you, Wonkas.
-Thank you, Wonkas.
-There you go.
Now read that card there.
When the curtain opens.
-Ah, okay, okay.
-Let's see first
what is behind me.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. I can't see it.
-Alright, okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just going to say
I'm very impressed
by someone's core strength,
okay.
[ Laughter ]
So the person who was able
to really discover
electricity, kites.
-Oh, Ben Franklin.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
He's carrying a British
red-headed,
like, pop singer.
-Ed Sheeran?
-Yes. Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And he's carrying --
-This is like a fever dream
I had.
-That was what I thought, too.
-Okay, good.
And he's carrying him.
You have children,
so you know what
you strap them in
when they were babies.
-Wait, so it's
Ben Franklin holding
Ed Sheeran in a Baby Bjorn?
-That's it.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations, guys.
-Oh, my God.
-And I have to say...
-Wow!
-...Ben's glute strength
right now is just blowing
my mind.
-This is amazing.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you, Ben. Thank you, Ed.
-All of our budget.
All of our budget is built
on this rotating stage.
-Alright. The production value.
-Alright, Anne Hathaway.
-What is in the sick mind
of "The Tonight Show" now?
-I know, whoever
wrote this, I know.
Let's see what is behind you.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Whip cracks ]
Oh, man. This is fantastic.
-Okay.
-I don't want this to stop.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so this is
a legendary movie character.
[ Laughter ]
Steven Spielberg,
George Lucas.
-"Jaws." No.
Uh, Obi-Wan Kenobi.
-No.
-Luke Skywalker.
Darth Vader.
-He's an adventurer.
-Adventurer?
-Adventurer. Yeah.
He's an archaeologist.
-Indiana Jones.
-Yes. Correct. And he is...
He is doing a famous dance
from a pop icon,
where it looks like you're kind
of sliding across the stage.
-The electric slide?
[ Laughter ]
-It's just like --
Michael Jackson.
Famous dance.
-Oh.
Moonwalking.
-Yeah. Can we get a beat?
Can we get a beat?
-Okay.
-And he's at a, um...
He's at a children's hangout
where, like,
you play for tickets
and you throw --
-Arcade.
-Kind of.
But it's a mouse.
-Chuck E. Cheese?
-Yes!
-No!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that.
-I mean, I mean...
♪♪
-Oh, yeah.
-Amazing.
-There you go, yeah. Oh!
-I mean...
-Now he's just walking
backwards.
He got tired.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Okay. Alright.
-Alright.
Now it is time to see
what's behind me!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
-This is a good laugh.
-Oh, that's so nice. Okay. Um...
A Prince song
that Julia Roberts sang
in the bathtub
in "Pretty Woman."
-Oh, gosh.
-♪ I just want your ♪
-Kiss.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And at Christmas,
it's the place that you stand
under when you kiss someone.
-Oh, very cancel right now.
You cannot do this
at an office party.
No.
-Oh.
-Mistletoe?
-Yes, it is, but don't do that.
-Do not do that.
-No, of course not.
-Someone's under
the mistletoe getting kissed.
-Um, at the place that
you can't do it under mistletoe.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
Julia Roberts is getting kissed?
-Go back.
-Okay. Sorry. Kiss?
-It's the song.
-Yes.
-But it's also a band.
So it's...
-[ Gasps ] The band KISS...
-Yes.
-...is under the mistletoe
at an office party?
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Got it.
Someone's getting kissed
under the mistletoe.
This is fantastic.
Anne Hathaway, everybody.
We're talking to Anne
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
That's fantastic.